so the Trump tax documents are starting
to filter out and it's instantly
terrible for Donald Trump instantly
evidence of financial fraud that we
believed for years was exactly what tax
documents would reveal now this is not
Donald Trump's tax returns I know that
there are people who maybe misunderstood
the headlines around this this is not
Trump's tax returns
ProPublica has obtained some Donald
Trump tax documents and they show
exactly what we've predicted for a long
time which is that Donald Trump is
playing very fast and loose with the
value of assets and profitability that
he claims depending on whether he's
trying to impress a lender or avoid
taxation specifically Pro Publica has
documents that relate to they relate to
I believe it's for manhattan buildings
that donald trump owns and they obtained
these documents through Freedom of
Information Act requests and the
documents were provided because these
documents were made public because Trump
appealed his property tax bill for the
buildings in question every year for in
some cases nine years in a row and so
what Pro Publica was able to do very
solid investigation was take the tax
records and compare them with loan
records that Donald Trump's lender
ladder capital made public when they
sold the debt but this isn't just
generally saying to a lender oh my
buildings worth 50 million and then
saying to the IRS the building's only
worth 25 million that is something I'm
sure Donald Trump is doing and Michael
Cohen told us that that's what Donald
Trump is doing but this is actually more
Donald Trump is actually lying about how
much rent the buildings are taking in
which is a much more calculated and
specific type of lie some might call it
fraud and in fact the number of real
estate professionals are calling it
exactly that so here's one example
Donald Trump told his lender that the
buildings earn twice as much rent that
one building earns twice as much rent as
what he told tax authorities in the same
year in 2017 okay both can't be true
those are lies this is financial fraud
another example Trump's building at 40
Wall Street I would walk by this
building every day because our david
pakman show studios in New York City
were like a block from Trump's building
at 40 Wall Street I'd walk by it every
day Trump told a lender that 40 Wall
Street went from being 59% leased to 95%
leased in a period of a few years but
then around the same time that he was
telling the lender it was 59% least he
told tax officials that the building was
81 percent leased now we're still trying
to figure out what the advantage to
doing that is there may be disincentives
to have empty buildings although I need
to research a little more about New York
City tenant landlord law and
restrictions and and provisions but
whatever the impetus was it doesn't make
sense and that's what's immediately
revealed by these documents sometimes
the exact motivation for the
discrepancies is not completely clear
does he want a stronger position to
receive money from a lender does he want
to minimize tax liability from the from
the government the state government of
New York but in other cases it's not
totally clear what the impetus is for
each lie but ProPublica went with
everything that they uncovered to a
dozen real estate professionals and the
real estate professionals were basically
unanimous in their assessment number one
there is no clear explanation for this
but number two these discrepancies are
and this is a quote versions of fraud
which would not be a surprise to anybody
who's been following this now this type
of fraud can lead to criminal charges
it's very unlikely that it will because
nothing has been sticking to Donald
Trump but note that Trump's former
personal attorney Michael Cohen and
Trump's former campaign chairman Paul
Manafort are in prison in part for
falsifying tax and bank records some of
which relate to real estate all in the
service of at least when it comes to
Michael Cohen Donald Trump so this is
very serious stuff the big picture the
big picture is that this is called
double bookkeeping
fraudsters typically do this they
maintain one set of books that's the set
you show certain entities and there's
another set of books that is either your
private set of books or the one that you
keep on hand to show other regulatory
entities depending on what is most
advantageous at the time really solid
investigation by Pro Publica and under
that I mean look you look at just a few
buildings and it's immediately clear
that something isn't right this is just
for buildings that they looked at
imagine if we were able to actually get
Donald Trump's tax returns what might be
in there his voters might not care sure
but it would be an absolute treasure
trove it's almost like Trump knows that
his tax returns going public would be
absolutely terrible for him and possibly
implicate him in crimes so he's going
completely out of his way to do
everything he can to prevent their
release exactly as we've been saying for
years back all the way since before he
even started the general election
debates against Hillary Clinton in the
2016 campaign will we ever see the tax
returns I don't know I don't know but I
hope that we do do it cappucci paid for
de Gracia Mila one of our sponsors
making the David Pakman show possible is
Babel the language learning app and
you'll get 25% off a subscription to
Babel when you click the link under this
video
Babel was founded in 2007 and now has
over a million paying subscribers
worldwide as one of the world's leading
language learning apps their learning
method has been examined numerous times
in scientific studies including one at
Yale in 2019 which found that 100
percent of participants who used babble
were able to improve their oral
proficiency with a new language within
just three months research found that
users learning Spanish on Babel only
needed to use the app for an average of
15 hours over a two-month period to
cover the requirements for one college
semester of Spanish I recently went to
Italy and use Babel to brush up on my
Italian for a few weeks leading up to
the trip and I was actually surprised at
how much I was able to absorb in such a
short
amount of time after practicing Italian
on the babble app I was able to hold
some conversations with locals in Italy
I could understand a lot more of the
Italian that I was hearing and the
progress I made was extremely inspiring
in keeping me going and continuing to
use the app to get even better I'm also
about to use the app to start learning
German which I'm looking forward to I
really would recommend babble to anyone
who watches our show and you can save
25% on a subscription to babble when you
click the link right underneath this
video